nassim taleb i don't know if you like
him or not have you read his book
black swan anti-fragile you know skin in
the game
he says if you want to go to page 8 adam
page 8 he says
bitcoin is worth zero and there's no
evidence that blockchain is a useful
technology black swan author nassim
talib says this is a business insider
story
he also said there's no evidence that
blockchain is useful technology a new
paper tally laid out four key arguments
against cryptocurrency
bitcoin failed to satisfy the notion of
currency without government in fact he
said bitcoin proved
to not even be a currency at all number
two bitcoin can neither be
a short nor long term store of value he
used
the famous juxtapose juxtaposition of
gold versus bitcoin which he said was
poor comparison
to illustrator's point and last final
two points
argued that bitcoin is not a reliable
inflation hedge contrary to some
analysts views
and is not a safe haven for investments
whether meant to protect against
government tyranny
or other catastrophes thoughts
do you agree or no are you more yes i
agree with him are you more no i don't
agree with that i'm more the market
agrees with him
the market agrees with them well last i
checked it was not exactly 65 000
anymore
look i'm gonna somebody who was here in
the office today
working with me earlier this morning
okay said danielle i want to thank you
i said why she said last time you were
here in florida
you said i understand everybody likes to
own
cryptocurrencies but take your take your
cost basis
off the table and just let your profits
run that way
if anybody ever asks you you can always
say i never lost a penny yep
she's like you saved me three thousand
dollars and three thousand dollars
is a lot in my world and i just want to
thank you because i just i let the
profits run but i took my cost basis off
the table
thank you daniel and i said anything for
them for doing that by the way good for
yeah cell discipline is very critical
can you explain what cost basis means
for somebody that's listening
you you put 500 into you bought you
spent 500
on on bitcoin yep and now it's worth 3
000. so you take the 500 off that's
right and that way you say i never lost
it that's right
yeah if it was volatile fine if it was
speculative fine
whatever i'm good to go i didn't i
didn't lose a penny call it a day
and you you wake up you look at yours
you know she's not
an investor she's not going to follow a
bit she's not going to give you the
opposing stuff
one day i woke up and it was like damn
it went from 65 to 30.
a lot of smart people are saying it's
going to get to a quarter million
dollars it's going to get two million
so what is more likely bitcoin to go to
one thousand or bitcoin to go to
a million dollars i would say one
thousand what are you gonna say
i think it's uh up up do you think it's
i don't know
you asked the question yeah you asked
the question to danielle
am i more likely to agree or disagree
with nassim talib right here yeah well
i'm taking the disagree cycle okay so i
actually you interviewed pomp
yep anthony pompliano i had the
opportunity to go down to the bitcoin
conference and interview him a couple of
weeks ago
smart guy sharp guy similar age we kind
of vibed
and this is the type of thing that i
think we need our
valuetainment someone like a pomp
pompliano debating this nasib talib
character
and let's find out what the actual truth
is right here because this is just
simply his opinion
because based on what he's saying here
there's
hundreds of thousands of people and and
maybe even dozens of
experts let's say willing to debate
every single point he made and why he's
wrong
like the fact that you can say that okay
chain technology quote unquote
um has not proven to what does he say
exactly
block is there's no evidence that
blockchain is useful technology here's
the debate that i'm i'm basically
bringing up
you constantly hear some of these
cryptos the dogecoins of the world or
the shimou enu's or whatever
maybe they're not here for the long stay
but you only hear that bitcoin's not
going anywhere
and blockchain technology is certainly
not going anywhere
and these smart contracts and everything
talib is a genius guy i'm sure he is his
assessment's been
very accurate over the years okay so for
a guy like that to make a comment you
have to give him credence this doesn't
mean you have to agree with them
but you have to give him credence on the
argument he's making i agree that's why
we're talking about it i agree
i want to pose a question to both of you
go forward let's look at the at the
chart
yep is bitcoin
a store of value the way you would think
of a currency as being some place you
can
store value well i'll use like the
the the trending internet joke about
bitcoin to prove your point yeah my
i bought bitcoin i got it at 35
000. yeah well now it's 31 000. no it's
48 000. no it's 22
000 and the definition of store value is
something that stores value and and
stays around the same rate right
stability
to be specific no it is not a store of
value however
let me just bring up one point and then
go back to you danielle if you said a
year ago
bitcoin went from 35 down to 33. oh my
god i went from six it's like it was at
less than ten thousand dollars yeah so
what are we talking about here it's
skyrocketed over the last year
and the fact that it's having a bad few
months all right
and i'm sure it'll have a good few
months in a few months that's the that's
why they say it's so violent so larry
larry fink
is is basically blackrock i'm listening
to him on bloomberg
tv this morning he's basically
reiterating what nassim said
saying the same thing as well yeah and
blackrock i think they have like
eight trillion dollars aum they're
ridiculous
rock is cream of the crop yes yeah
they're at the top so
not to be confused with black stone yeah
but but
here's here's the thing that we have to
also realize as well and put some weight
behind it
i own a uh uh probably the best zion
williamson rookie card
okay and it's probably a card that's got
legs to be a 5 million
card in the next 24 months okay it's
that it's that good of a card
zion jumps 46 inches he's 285 pounds
he's six eight he's a beast he's a
monster he doesn't want to be a
uh uh uh a uh uh pelican anymore he's
not happy with the team
he just announced a couple days ago
which means he probably wants to be
traded to the next sooner rather than
later he wants to go out and run with
randall let's just say he wants to be a
nicky setter before
he goes there say he does something
special okay
that's a 5 million card i want to
believe this guy's gonna dominate
because i
have vested interest in him have an
incredible career right
but i also know that his body and his
style of play
could get him hurt to the point where
that card goes from whatever i
paid for 350 000 that card could go down
to 150
000 100 000 and i take a big hit right
okay
so a lot of people who are saying yes
bitcoin is this
it's of course it's they have no clue
what they're talking about
they generally own bitcoin and a lot of
people that are saying there's no way in
the world bitcoins
there's no value that it has they also
probably don't own bitcoin right
so you have to kind of know the the
people opinions is also based on that
exactly so the whole skin in the game
touche you know with
him writing a book ski in the game so
you have to also realize where people
are coming from so
i want to hear it from the people that
are in the middle who are not in that
say i think it's going places
or who are who are in you know who are
not in that are saying
you know uh uh who are in and are saying
i don't know if it's gonna go anywhere
i'm just in there hoping that if it does
i'll make some money on it but
i'm not 100 sold on the uh what's going
to happen what's going to happen with
this
you know that's portfolio management 101
yeah if it's if it's speculative
if it's volatile then you limit it to
five percent yeah
mm-hmm let it ride there's a lot of
smart people that are doing five percent
oh i know yeah so there's a lot of
people so so for the
people that are bitcoin pro bitcoin and
people that are anti-bitcoin
a lot of smart people that are saying
look i don't know what's gonna happen
with this quite honestly i'm not smart
enough to figure it out and none of us
are
we're going to keep a little bit of
money in there but not a lot and we'll
see what happens i mean
you i did a whole bitcoin episode on
valuetainment economics and basically i
said here's my two cents here's the
bottom line
the big boys and the big girls in the in
the in wall street and
you know they're putting somewhere
between three and eight percent into the
crypto world okay
so let that be your guide if you're
gonna put five percent of your
investment strategy
into bitcoin or into a crypto cool you
know you know don't put in more than you
can lose
when i go down to these to these cr like
bitcoin conference a couple weeks ago
i asked the question what percentage of
your portfolio of all your money
is in crypto and you get these answers
where 95
of all my money is encrypted oh yeah
even our friend gerard here he says i'm
over leveraged to the t on crypto and
they know people where it's 100 plus
where they've taken on debt to buy
bitcoin well that's an aggressive
situation
i mean you're talking about those are
believers those are believers they think
that
cryptocurrency is the future and you
cannot tell them otherwise and
if they're right they're the big winner
if they lose they're out i mean i think
it hasn't
i don't think it's been stress tested i
mean the only regulators that have
clamped down really are
the chinese so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye